[Music]
personnel economics is the application
of economic principle statistics
economic theory mathematics even to
questions that were traditional human
resource questions so questions that
people would not normally think of as
lending themselves easily to economics
motivating workers hierarchical kinds of
questions how much authority should you
give to your workers those issues that
were traditional in human resources were
dealt with in a quite a different way so
if you think about organizational
behavior which is another field in our
business school and in most business
schools they think of it more from the
psychology point of view or sometimes
sociology point of view whereas I deal
with it and to be honest I would say a
harder nosed way more mathematical more
statistical way and that's what
personnel economics is about
if you look across countries and you say
in which countries have workers enjoyed
the highest wage gains say over the past
15 years and then you say in which
countries have workers been most
productive in the past 15 years what
you'll find is that the correlation
between those two is very very strong
what that means is that if you go across
countries and you look at these
countries that are being effective in
raising worker productivity are also the
ones where workers are seeing their
wages grow so that's really important
one of the most traditional ways to
motivate workers and to increase both
their productivity and their earnings is
to pay them something that's called a
peace rate most of most of us are
familiar with peace rates there are a
couple of obvious examples
uber is a peace rate why is uber a peace
rate well because you basically get paid
for the number of rides that you give
that you you actually depends on the
amount of time that you spend driving
but it more than that it depends on the
actual amount of miles that you drive
and so they're paying you on the basis
of your output that's a very effective
way to motivate people and of course is
if you look at Buber drivers they're
pretty darn motivated they work pretty
hard they work long hours they are very
good at figuring out the system how best
to get rides where to locate at certain
points in time what does that form the
fact that they are directly paid on the
basis of their output so that's a great
motivator
how do you motivate people in situations
where output is difficult to measure
most of those kinds of jobs are
managerial jobs and managerial jobs are
important for the economy because they
are the basis of much of our
productivity it's not just the workers
it's the people who are managing the
workers supervising them teaching them
guiding them how do you motivate the
teachers and the and the motivators
essentially what you have to do is you
have to pay on the basis of relative
performance so some thing that I came up
with a long time ago again in my youth
it's called tournament theory
what tournament theory is about is it's
kind of obvious when you think about it
it's not it's not very complicated you
kind of wonder why no one thought about
it before but it's basically the idea
that firms structure their compensation
in the same way that they had that
people run tournaments sports
tournaments so for example if you think
about Wimbledon tennis match and you say
how does Wimbledon work well Wendell
works Wimbledon works by paying a prize
to the winner and second-place prize to
the loser of the finals because that's
the second-place person in the
tournament the difference between the
winners prize and the losers prize
serves to motivate those players now
they would be motivated even if they
didn't have that prize but depending on
the size of that prize they'll be
motivated even more so for example if
there were a million pounds at stake and
when winning that tournament people
would be highly motivated to play and
that's what happens in business so what
tournament theory talks about is first
of all how to set up those implicit comp
contests compen the competition between
these workers do it in a way that
doesn't undermine the firm because
sometimes competition can be bad they'll
they'll work to sabotage one another
essentially because they're trying to
get the next promotion and then finally
to think about how big a raise should
you give those individuals when they get
promoted from one level to another
- both motivate them below and then give
them incentives above
another way that workers are sometimes
compensated is on the basis of the team
why would you do that well sometimes
people need to cooperate and in order to
get them to cooperate you have to pay
them on the basis of their joint output
not on the basis of their individual
output let me give you an example
there's a good example by one of my
colleagues here Catherine Shaw who with
a couple of co-authors did a very nice
study of a firm in Brazil that was
actually a law firm and what they did
was they had initially paid their
lawyers on the basis of their Billings
straight on the on the number of
Billings that's a measure of output
sounds great because you can easily
observe it you basically know who's
doing what you can motivate them very
effectively but here's the problem
because they were being paid on the
basis of their own Billings the senior
lawyers who had the ability to allocate
cases to one another took all the great
cases for themselves even when they
weren't necessarily the best partner to
handle the job and so what the firm did
is they said our junior people some of
whom are highly qualified to be working
on these cases are not getting the work
because the senior guys are taking it
all for themselves what do we do we've
got to change the compensation structure
so that you're paid not only on your own
Billings but you're essentially paid on
the profitability of the firm now
because you're paid on the profitability
of the whole firm or of a sector of the
firm you care not only about how well
you do but you also care about how well
your your co-workers do as a result the
the whole there was an enormous
transformation in the way that work was
allocated and an enormous transformation
as well in the productivity of the firm
so profits went up Billings actually
went up and the work was better handled
and people were much happier as a result
of that
team compensation can be very effective
one problem with team compensation is it
doesn't always work why not there's
something in economics called the free
rider problem I'm sure people many of
your listeners have heard about that but
the free rider problem comes about when
you have an incentive to shirk and
basically put the burden on someone else
some of some of your viewers may
remember when they were in school
perhaps even at Stanford Business School
although we don't have many shirkers
here but you if you're involved in a
team project suppose five of you have a
homework assignment you have to get
together and write up the the write up
the assignment for the whole team
sometimes one person will work harder
than another person and sometimes even a
teammate might be critical of the other
teammate because of the behavior the
other teammate not putting in the the
appropriate amount of effort the
appropriate amount of time so the free
rider effect comes comes about in teams
and as the team size gets larger the
free rider effect becomes more
pronounced because your ability to
affect the total output of the team gets
smaller and smaller so team output a
team compensation can be affected vary
it in a strong way as long as the teams
are structured appropriately first of
all you have to make sure that the teams
in involve people who are highly
complementary to another one another so
you want to make sure that I'm working
with someone whose output will benefit
greatly from my input and vice-versa you
also want to make sure that the team is
small enough so that we can observe each
other we can monitor each other we can
motivate each other and that's an
important component as well so firms can
use team compensation but they have to
be pretty careful about the way they set
it up
people often work for a long time in a
company and the question is what do you
do to motivate managers when they're
essentially done with the tournament
what do I mean by done with a tournament
look at me I've been the equivalent of a
middle level manager for most of my life
I'm a senior professor at Stanford but
there's nowhere for me to go I have no
aspirations and be a Dean or anything
like that so how do you keep me
motivated well again there there are
ways that you can do this that have to
do with compensation in addition to
non-monetary forms but let me give you
the one that's compensation so when I
was a young guy and I was working really
hard trying to get tenure at this point
it was at the University of Chicago and
I was looking at my senior senior
colleagues and while they were very
smart and very productive people I still
thought that I was working a lot harder
and even more productive I wrote a lot
of papers in those days I still try to
write a lot of papers but when I was a
young person I was probably better at it
than I am now
and yet I was paid a lot less than my
senior colleagues and I thought why is
that isn't this kind of crazy I'm the
guy doing all the work and they're guys
making all the money and so I thought
about it and I realized well actually
that motivates me because what happens
is as a result of seeing my senior
colleagues make a lot of money I want to
be a senior colleague and that was true
throughout most of my career so when I
was in my 30s and 40s at that point I
was already a tenured professor with an
endowed chair there was pretty much
nowhere for me to go in the tournament
but I still cared a lot about being
successful in the organization not only
because I wanted Stanford to succeed and
I wanted myself to succeed but also
because I wanted to be well treated in
my old age which I have now reached and
I am well treated and I think part of
that is because I try to continue to be
productive but part of that is also
payoff for what I did as a younger man
and that motivates the younger
generation it motivates the 40 and 50
year olds many of whom are still very
productive and we want to keep those
people very productive by their ability
to see how Stamper treats me
they say alright if I if I perform well
I understand that some way I'll some day
I'll be like loser and maybe I'll be a
little bit overpaid but it's okay it's
compensation for what I'm doing right
now
[Music]